I think kratom is a cure for the opioid
epidemic I really do
I know that's a bold statement now
there's something on the market that's
safe that can stop things from happening
like my brother dying and these [__]
politicians want to be hey you know what
let's shut this down like and then it's
not that black and white and it's not
that easy
Chris Bell is the acclaimed documentary
filmmaker behind 2008 bigger stronger
faster a fascinating look at the
intersection of America's
winner-take-all culture and
performance-enhancing drugs you don't
mess with Hulk Hogan and you certainly
don't mess with America it's follow-up
2015's prescription thugs delves into
the growing use of pharmaceuticals
suddenly my hero started to die Mothra
but it wasn't from steroids it was from
drugs Phil's new films slated for
release this summer is a leap of faith
it examines kratom a plant with a
devoted community of users who attest to
its powerful therapeutic benefits it's
been used to relieve pain for centuries
they call it an all-natural godsend yet
the US Drug Enforcement Administration
or DEA has labeled kratom a dangerous
drug and recently tried to ban it so can
you just give us the basics you know
what is it how do people use it what are
its effects are here kratom is just a
plant comes from Southeast Asia and the
same family as a coffee plant it's
probably about as addictive as coffee so
before we even get to that point I'll
just tell you what it's been shown to do
anecdotally now not in any real studies
because we're not a-holes a lot of
studies is a kill pain fight depression
site PTSD anxiety and internally it
actually just makes you feel good like
it gives you a state of euphoria and a
lot of people are afraid of that because
they say well it gets you high and I'm
like well no because I don't think
coffee gets you high so I think it's in
the same realm and how do people take it
basically it's just a plant on
adulterated plan and they ground up the
plant and people take it as a tea or
capsule so what kind of people have you
met or what is your what is the typical
kratom user what do people use it for I
was pretty shocked by the typical kratom
user because I thought it was going to
be honestly just like a bunch of
dirtbags like I thought it's gonna be a
bunch of like hippie you know kind of
you know like yeah man these creative
cool and like it's not like that at all
the community is so kind of
straight-laced like normal everyday
people with nine-to-five jobs and they
they're using it really the fight pain
and a lot of them are using it to fight
depression I just interviewed a friend
of mine
and dr. Murray Holcomb he lives in
Austin Texas in the Sun grant was an
addict and if it's not for kratom he
suffers such bad depression that he said
he'd go right back to pills and so he
takes kratom every day he's got a job
he's a good kid and it's like those
people are the ones that I don't want to
see suffer and his father said to me
kratom is not the thing that your kids
going to seek out kratom just the thing
that your kid's going to seek out when
he's already messed up on drugs to get
off of the drugs and are there any
negative side effects of kratom or have
people become addicted there's negative
side effects to everything there's
people that have gone to rehab for
kratom some people can't handle certain
things like overeating for example - we
have a huge obesity epidemic in this
country but we want to point the finger
at things that don't really matter that
much let's take let's take the real
issue into consideration here we're
prescribing oxycontin the [__]
11-year olds
seriously like that's the issue we're
making it easier and easier for kids to
get prescribed adderall and Ritalin and
psych meds and our kids are walking
around like [__] zombies and now
there's something on the market that's
safe that can stop things from happening
like my brother dying and these [__]
politicians want to be hey you know
let's shut this down like and then it's
not that black and white and it's not
that easy
and if people want to make a change in
this country we need to rise up and we
need to speak because when we spoke
about marijuana killing you know all
these pain and do you know that they've
been able to fight the powers that be
and make that a reality and I truly
believe what my friend Joe Rogan says
the more people that have access to
things like marijuana and things like
freedom the better of a society will
have because everybody's walking around
stressed out how they're going to pay
their next bill how they're going to
support their family we're just so
stressed and that's why everybody's
fighting over Donald Trump and that's
why everybody's arguing and yelling and
so kratom could be the very first cure
for Donald Trump yeah yeah Donald Trump
I think train about your benefit I think
freedom is a cure for the opioid
epidemic I really do and I know that's a
bold statement and people say how do you
know because I've done this [__] like I
went the pill route I've taken all I've
taken every single form of opiate that
you can take for pain and this is better
from an early age my big brother Mad Dog
was my hero we always knew he was
destined for greatness so when he told
us he was going to wrestle for the WWE
like our heroes the holster and the
warrior we believed he'd finally made it
the sky was the limit for the Bell
brothers and Mad Dog was leading a
charge Bell and his two brothers were
avid power lifters and body builders the
striking story of the family's
experience with steroids and other drugs
is a narrative thread that runs through
his documentaries he filmed bigger
stronger faster as his older brother Mad
Dog was descending into his darkest
period of abuse I went from a guy who
used steroids to a guy who used steroids
in pot and I still needed to escape
reality so I started taking ecstasy
cocaine asked $1 and Belle who had
always resisted drugs ultimately turned
the camera on himself in prescription
thugs to reveal his own dark secret you
see the truth was Mad Dog wasn't the
only belt brother that was popping too
many pills I'm just trying to tell you
how I feel as a mother I am broken to my
soul my heart prescription thugs we were
it's a very honest look at your own
addiction as well as what's going on
writ large in the country what was your
journey like how did you get addicted
and how did you find kratom yeah so my
my journey was really interesting I was
like lifting weights and winning all
these national powerlifting competitions
I had a genetic hip issue and with
powerlifting and the hip issue they were
just so bad and I got so bad so quick
that I needed a double hip replacement
surgery and I needed it pretty quickly
and it had both hips in one day and
after that I've just never been the same
like you know after they did that I was
put on opiate painkillers I went into
the doctor and I said hey Doc you know
I'm in a lot of pain here and he said I
said I'm debilitated and he said you're
not debilitated you're using the wrong
terminology I'm like well I don't know
what the [__] you call it but I can't
walk you know and you did this to me and
you need to fix it and he was like he's
basically like kind of get out of my
office kind of thing like I didn't do
this to you your problems within you so
I go home feeling terrible about myself
and I go home feeling like [__] you know
so I just continue to do
for the next few years and when she no
he calls me up two years later and said
I know why your hip hurts I can see on
your x-ray right now we never caught it
the socket it was never attached in your
hip I'm like oh now you see it you know
sided who did it redone
then a month after I got my hip replaced
my brother died
my older brother Mad Dog who's like our
hero the whole reason why we played
football and lifted weights and down in
the wrestling and did everything you
know it just died after another relapse
Mad Dog crawled up the stairs of a sober
living facility and was barely even able
to knock on the door
a month later he was sober two months
later he was dead I was like I'm not
going to go out that way there's just no
way I left that way and why don't you
know like a yearly I was doing the same
[__] I went the same way you know like I
was just depressed and I was sad and I
was hurting inside and I didn't know
what to do and there was nobody that
really helped what you described as kind
of a common situation for a lot of
people across the country right they
start out with an injury or something
like that they start taking pills yeah
something happens and then they fall
into that can you give us a scale of
what is what is the level of opiate and
opioid abuse in the u.s. I just talked
to my friend that lives in Louisville
Kentucky and you said if you you know if
you're 20 years old and you got a
paycheck
you're doing pills you know that's what
he said he's like everybody here is
doing it that's how he fell into it you
know we represent 5% of the world's
population we take 75% of the world's
prescription drugs and I think that's a
lot of people I'll just happen to me or
that happened to me and that's the same
thing with like with kratom it's like if
you're in pain you know you need to find
something that's going to help you you
can't worry about what other people
think you know and that that's a
reaction that you've gotten right so
people say well now you're just addicted
to your great it now you're a trade in
one addiction for the other Mike no it's
not an addiction though I'm training an
addiction for a plant that's very safe
so the way that it works is that it does
activate the same opioid receptors as
say heroin but it yeah the enemy
receptor so the difference is it doesn't
bind to the receptor it attaches to the
receptor does that make sense yeah and
so the effect of that is that somebody
who is addicted to opiates it would have
that craving reduced
they would not get ya it's blocking the
phrasing but it's not getting you that
high I found it in the middle of doing
prescription thugs and I tried it and I
think I was expecting to get high and
the prot that was the problem
somebody on Twitter somebody said to me
hey have you ever heard of kratom you
know what when I was doing prescription
thugs and I said yeah that [__] don't
work and then it comes back and bites me
in the ass because I'm now on reddit
they're like I don't think Chris Bell
should be representing the kratom
community because like what would you
said a year ago but to me that's a
testament to the fact that like I didn't
think it did anything because I was
looking for I was looking to get high
and now I've been taking it every day
since I actually went to Thailand and
after taking it for three months I was
able to get off of it for two weeks with
no ill effects no side effects no
withdrawals at all the only thing that
happened to me was I had to go back to
taking Tylenol and Advil in a
combination to kill the pain I'd have to
take two advil and two Tylenol each time
and that adds up and that's going to
hurt your liver it's going to kill your
kidneys and we don't want that you know
so I think having something a natural
alternative is a great way to go so just
to clarify a little bit so opiates or
things that are derived directly from
poppies right like heroin opium yeah and
then opioids are the synthetic synthetic
version usually they have a base from
the poppy plant and then like
synthetically derived from there the one
that oxycontin or the one that's
completely synthetic from what I've
heard is fentanyl and that's why it's
like the mobilization the most potent
fentanyl was also implicated in Prince's
death yes and some other celebrities
didn't read all right like I know
Michael Jackson I be related to a lot of
debts and kratom hasn't had any debts
according to the DEA however 15 people
died from taking kratom in the two years
before the agency tried to ban it to put
that in context there are thousands of
deaths annually related to aspirin and
similar over-the-counter painkillers and
Belle disputes the DA's claim that
kratom was the cause of death and even
this relatively tiny number of cases
there was like 15 deaths altogether nine
of them were in Sweden all this kratom
was laced with fentanyl and nine people
died when she banned fentanyl not ban
kratom and I mean it's just so asinine
and ridiculous and people need to get
their head out of their ass you know
there's a lot of reasons why people
would need serious opiates like fentanyl
and those reasons are like cancer
patients and people with terminal
diseases and I would never ever
take it away from them but who's to say
that we might not be able to give those
people a better quality of life if we
studied freedom so basically what
happened is the DEA over this past
summer they temporarily put it into
Schedule one the most restrictive
category along with heroin and bunch of
other bad drugs
the FDA has decided ruled after it's
considered judgment that there is no
medical value we are bound by its
scientific determinations in that arena
it's in schedule 1 therefore because it
has no medical value there is a high
potential for abuse so if we made an
error and perhaps some people think we
did I frankly do not then we air it on
the side of protecting the public and
I'm ok with that
and they underestimated the community
for kratom because there was this big
they actually never got to the point
where it got banned the blowback on this
was incredible
the DEA has never seen anything like it
the DEA when they issued the ban said we
will not hear any public comment this is
getting banned on this date and that's
it so we started tweeting about it and
we started sharing it and we got over a
hundred thousand signatures so then
there was a march on Washington so then
they open it up to public comment so I
called Joe Rogan I'm like you think we
could go on and talk about this they
said absolutely I would love to so we
really need you Chris
the documentary is actually important
after that episode Eric we had 23,000
comments on the website so like that
just was and that was in like a Monday
and so that that comment period ended on
December 1st 71st scene and so do you
have any indication what what their own
timeline anybody learned anything about
no since December 1st nobody's hearing
anything you know when I talked to the
DEA
it wasn't happy December 1st - right ah
no he said if I could tell you the truth
I don't see this going much much
anywhere like anytime soon you know
because of the blow boat so they were
referring to the band yeah they were
saying I don't think it's going to go
through and I don't think anything
really yeah but they'll never speak to
anybody on camera but they should be
transparent right but they're not and
the Meuse the FDA and that's a big
problem with this country if those
organizations were transparent and we
knew it was going on we'd be able to
like make a lot better decisions also we
might not bash them so much because we
understand that they they have a very
difficult job so marijuana is good
example
the DEA put marijuana and schedule 1
which basically is the only category
that says that it has no accepted
medical use and the catch-22 there is
that people can't do research on it they
can't do medical research because it's
in schedule 1 so there's no way to get
it out of Schedule one right now that
applies also things like psilocybin
mushrooms ayahuasca is another one but
kratom is a little bit different because
it hasn't been banned so why doesn't
that medical research exists for kratom
that would counteract that you know
inclination to put it in schedule one
there is like the NIH and an
International Institute of drug abuse
and I've heard that they're looking into
doing some studies on kratom I really
hope that they do and my film is
actually going to push for that that's
sort of a big ask it has to be a vested
interest though from a pharma company
that says like hey look we can stop this
opiate crisis simply study this I don't
know why that's not happening I mean
that's really something that like maybe
Pharma has like banded together and say
like we like the opiate model and we
want to keep it you know I mean the
opiate model is a huge model it's not
just one company now a renegade drug
company would be smart to come in and
say hey let's study this and let's put
this on the market but you got to
remember it's also like an eight billion
dollar process so why stop why stop the
money machine that you have rolling to
start an eight billion dollar process to
get a drug approved you know on average
you cost several billion dollars and
takes a decade to get a new drug
approved by the FDA but as Bell explains
in his documentary Pharma lobbyists have
carved out exceptions for themselves and
in 1992 Congress passed the Prescription
Drug User Fee Act which allows pharma
companies to pay a fast-track fee to the
FDA of up to $350,000 per drug to speed
up the approval process
despite Belle's objections to this
process and to the DA's treatment of
kratom he believes the agency should do
more to restrict the supply of
prescription opioids the DEA is the one
that tells Pharma how many they can make
why are they allowed to make ten times
the amount of pills we need why are
there so many pills on the street put at
the same token right you were saying
about how your doctor was reluctant to
prescribe you pills that you really need
yeah I sorry but I actually was in
legitimate pain so I don't that I rather
than like so I don't think my doctor was
wrong for cutting me off he was wrong
for not helping me find a solution I
guess my question is more about like the
DA's action so because you know we find
that like they have put in place
programs that limit you know the number
of prescriptions that can go out tract
doctors and you know we don't find a
reduction in the illicit use of pills we
find people who have chronic pain who
can't get pills anymore that they need
because address those streets right so
you know oxycontin they spent years
reformulating the pills so that they
were not as easily snorty bull and their
sales went down like 80 percent yeah
there's a long way down when they after
they did it and that's why they want to
go global right and what we find after
that is that with the you know the
decrease in oxycontin prescriptions
there was a rise with heroin use heroin
abuse for street drug abuse so you know
pushes it pushes a lot of people to the
black market so do you think that there
are effective ways to stop it at the
supply side like can we just ban things
or is that a rehashing of the drug war
that we've had for decades that hasn't
passed I think so I think that if there
wasn't as many pills available I think
that's the issue is like they're they
just there's such an abundance that
that's where that's where people are
able to get them however you can cut the
number of pills on the street out I
would say would be like the things that
they need to try to focus on and I might
be completely wrong like we might you
know we might say hey let's just make
half the amount of pills and make half
the amount of pills they might have the
same problem the matter spawn because
might be harder to get for people they
might do more aggressive actions to get
it so we don't really know but I think
the DEA knows I think that that's their
job and they should they should figure
it out but I think if we started looking
at like well how can we help how can we
service addicts besides throwing them in
prison okay let's find things that we
can help them do that will help keep
their
brain go on the right way so but now it
sounds like you're advocating for kind
of less intervention right you don't
want people to go to prison which is
what happens with ready I mean we're
always right yeah you know do you think
that the best thing that the DEA might
be able to do or the FDA is to kind of
loosen some of those regulations so that
other people can come in whether it's
create them or whether it's you know new
FL yeah yeah sure and get that passed
more easily so that these types of
monopolies dentist and Big Pharma all
right I think um you know I think the
path to getting a drug approved needs to
be fixed to make things so hard and
difficult to take a look at I think
limits a lot of things try this try this
one way kratom could avoid the drug
approval process is if the FDA and DEA
treated like other botanicals on the
market which are classified as dietary
supplements but Bell also thinks these
substances should be more tightly
regulated to ensure standardized
ingredients and dosages the supplement
industry is regulated to an extent but
the extent that it's regulated isn't
really good enough because you don't
have to show efficacy you just have to
show safety making supplements used to
be like making prescription drugs you
had to prove your product is safe and
effective before you could sell now you
don't have to prove your product is safe
at all and the FDA has to prove that if
not safe if they want to take it off the
market what happened there was 1994
Orrin Hatch wrote a bill called the de
chelly Act dietary supplement and Health
Act and what that said is that anything
that's already on the market
we were going to say it's generally
regarded as safe trading has been on the
market for you know 2,000 years in
Thailand over here I know a guy that's
been selling it since 1984 so we've
definitely been on the market before
then and then I asked the DEA I'm like
why why would you try to ban this if
it's been on the market you know the
rules and they said well because it was
on the market but nobody ever really
knew about it yeah so there's there's a
lot of argument that kratom might only
be able to be legal if it's considered a
supplement sure so if the concern is
that the FDA is preventing kratom from
being a legitimate competitor to these
these other analgesics that the
pharmaceutical industry is selling why
do you think that tighter regulation on
supplements is the answer given that you
know they've used that in the past to
kind of constrict the supply and so I
think
better to regulate it and have something
where people trust it and people like
okay this isn't the boogeyman this isn't
something that's the unknown but at the
same time if regulation is going to mean
it has to get banned for a while or
something I don't want to leave the
people stranded that are taking it now
it's more like the creative industry
needs to regulate itself according to
the FDA compliance so I know as an
ingredient as a plant that the kratom
works but what I don't know is that if I
buy certain brands I don't know that
it's actually create them they're not
testing it in their facilities and
that's what we need to fix the way that
kratom is being sold and marketed in the
United States you can only buy it kind
of at smoke shops it's not really in the
health food stores the brand that my
friend owns he's the only one doing like
FDA testing FDA compliance so I know
because I know how much money it costs
him right if you're going to do
something we have to do it right because
we look like a joke otherwise bill was
recently barred from speaking at his
former rehab facility because he uses
kratom while he credits AAA for helping
him get clean he believes that the
abstinence only approached championed by
the organization isn't always the best
way to help addicts the issue is for me
how do I address my pain that's another
thing it's like abstinence only from
what like everybody in rehab smokes
everybody yeah I was the only one that
didn't smoke so you know what [__] those
people you know what I mean like
abstinence only it's like are you
probably the ones that are smoking in
rehab you know or their sex addicts so
they you know they have all these other
issues and and they're like preaching
abstinence only because they don't want
you to have any fun because they can't
have fun and I don't like that part of
it and I don't think there's anything
wrong with it it's just wrong with if
you're going to preach it to me right
like they want to call it a disease
they're the ones that call it a disease
now a they call it a disease you can't
treat a disease with religion you can't
it's a mental condition and a mental
condition can be treated with therapy
and it's the only way I think you can
really treat it and that's all ia is
actually therapy right you know but they
want you to choose they want you have a
higher power right and all stuff like
that and when I was in that just
couldn't grasp that concept I would
imagine that they would say you know
you're a particular case you have a lot
of pain most addicts would probably just
you know you're let's say heroin addicts
right you're giving the methadone you're
just substituting another it'll be it
for this opiate so you know do you
support kind of harm reduction
strategies like that where there
methadone or suboxone other ones
fox-owned like needle exchange programs
they're like anything that can help I
think the best way to help people though
is to empower them and allow them to
have things like kratom and these other
kind of things like making it so they
don't get into harmful situations harm
reduction as you said I think that's a
good thing because I think after awhile
people will get out of it you know like
I got sick of it I couldn't do it
anymore
I think that's what most people you know
and some people die before that that's
the thing I felt it was 100 percent
curable and anybody that reached out for
help gets better a main theme of Bell's
films is distinguishing between
responsible drug use and misuse
particularly for sick people and
athletes what for you is kind of the
line between healthy use and abuse I
think abuse is when you know something's
toxic but you take it anyway however I
have to say like if your goal is to be a
professional bodybuilder then drug abuse
might be part of it you know what I mean
like I don't saying that you're not
abusing and saying drug abuse might be
part of that if you want to play in the
NFL drug abuse could probably gonna be
part of it you know if you want to fight
in the UFC drug abuse is going to be
part of that and you just have to be
ready for that because you know using
for a medical reason using for a certain
effect so do you think that there are
certain performance-enhancing drugs that
should be outlawed from sport or do you
think it should just be fair game that
we're kidding us all the time I don't
think any I don't think it should be
anything goes if it's anything goes
there's just too much craziness out
there but I believe in baseline testing
for testosterone and growth hormone
because growth hormone is going to help
with CTE with a brain injuries and so
will testosterone so where it becomes
more dangerous for them not to be on it
I also you mean like treated by their
doctors yeah treated by the dog they're
not going to treat them any way they
want and whatever whatever is on other
doctor got you know whatever is on the
doctor chart better be in their body and
that's it do you think that it's
cheating
basically if somebody's doing something
that's not hurting themselves of course
as the rules are set up it's cheating I
just think this whole system should be
different I guess I don't feel so pure
about sports you know I just did a
podcast about Lance Armstrong here today
I know a lot of people hate them and a
lot of people hate a lot of people died
on they hate the line that's what we
hate you know
think that people hide so much and then
it's like I got you right you know the
reason why Lance Armstrong got caught
was Peter because he came back but also
because they wanted to get him they
wanted to get Barry Bonds they were
definitely ought to get those guys and
you know Lance Armstrong is a childhood
hero of mine so that yeah the big thing
growing up I followed all of his races
and it was disappointing but at that
point you know dozens of other cyclists
everybody that he competed again I think
when I pour that somehow the top 18 got
like how did yeah which i am i doing a
documentary together about this all of
stuff and i was shaking his hand ago you
got screwed you know I think you're the
best guy that ever ever got on a bike
you know and he's like thanks man I
really appreciate that but I really
believe that you know I'm gonna leave it
if you took all the other people you
know and it's about heart
right live and he's like got this freaky
weird crazy you know like anybody else
could have done and it's taken the drugs
that he did but look at my boss he's
like six eight with webbed feet like
yeah
excuse me the sweat but he smokes
marijuana yeah all that Rios that's the
problem
[Music]